comenzó el juicio político el presidente
de Guillermo lasso se defendió ante la
asamblea nacional
fue creado tu actuación
Resuelve los problemas del pueblo ni de
nadie
tras el discurso del presidente de los
137 asambleístas participarán en el
debate por un tiempo de 10 minutos una
vez finalizados los discursos hay cinco
días para convocar de nuevo a la
asamblea para la votación hay distintas
posibilidades si se consiguen menos de
92 votos para destituir a lasso este
continuará en el poder de lograrlos el
vicepresidente Alfredo borrero pasaría a
ser presidente hasta el final del
mandato en 2025 otra posibilidad Es que
la corte constitucional invalide el
proceso por irregularidades Al iniciar
el juicio político algo que ha pedido
Guillermo lasso la última opción es que
el presidente invoque la muerte Cruzada
esto significaría la disolución del
Congreso y un gobierno de seis meses vía
decreto antes de que haya elecciones
esto podrían callar el proceso
nuevamente ya que la oposición podría
considerar que este mecanismo no se
puede activar en pleno juicio político
al presidente le acusan de peculado
También conocido como malversación por
un contrato del que le acu que tenía
conocimiento de las condiciones
perjudiciales para el estado y contra el
que no habría actuado lasso dice que
este contrato viene de la administración
de Lenin Moreno y que se limitaron a
obedecer las recomendaciones de la
contraloría